[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 13 janvier la
crise sanitaire accentuer une pratique
le télétravail entreprises et
administrations se sont adaptés mais
quels sont les enjeux économiques et
sociaux c'est ce qu'a voulu savoir
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
la vice présidente en charge du
développement économique alexandra
rosetti nous dévoilera les résultats
d'une enquête réalisée auprès de
télétravailleurs nous entendrons aussi
la voie d'une chef d'entreprise dans
l'actualité également depuis fin
décembre la ville de la verrière a
déployé huit médiateurs sociaux ils vont
à la rencontre des habitants avec un
double objectif la tranquillité publique
et l'insertion sociale enfin un mot de
sport rencontre avec antoine ghibaudo
c'est l'un des sportifs à suivre en 2021
et à 15 ans il fait partie des meilleurs
tennismen de sa génération
et aussi nous parlerons d'un mur
antibruit en test aux mureaux depuis six
mois
comme je vous le disais en titre on va
parler télétravail la crise sanitaire à
accélérer le développement de cette
pratique qui permet de travailler depuis
son domicile dans les entreprises et
administrations
et justement l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines dévoile pour tv 78
les résultats d'une enquête à ce sujet
réalisée auprès de télétravailleurs du
territoire pour nous en parler alexandra
rosetti bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes donc
je le rappelle vice présidente en charge
du développement économique au sein de
l'agglomération est également maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux alors sky a lancé
une enquête comme je le disais auprès
des télétravailleurs du territoire un
sondage qui a été réalisé du 9 au 22
décembre dernier via des campagnes
facebook principalement selon les
résultats 92% des sondés 2010 personne
précisément apprécieraient de
télétravailler à sky d'abord alexandre
rosetti un peu plus de 2000 personnes
ont répondu à ce sondage est ce que les
personnes interrogées travaillent à
saint quentin en yvelines ou bien or
saint quentin pouvez vous nous préciser
un petit peu le profil de ces personnes
sondées tout à fait alors d'abord
d'abord je tiens à remercier les deux
mille dix personnes qui ont répondu
parce que ca c'est un beau taux de
réponse alors ce sont des personnes qui
peuvent travailler à 51 puisque grande
partie d'entre eux 61% ont l'habitude
d'utiliser leur voiture pour aller
travailler et font en moins de pas moins
de 45 minutes
donc c'est forcément des gens qui
travaillent on va dire dans le bassin
d'emploi de saint quentin
pour autant il viendrait quand même un
tiers qui utilisent les transports en
commun et qui font plus de 45 minutes de
trajet est donc on peut penser qu'il
travaille peut-être d'habitude plutôt
sur peut-être sur paris par exemple et
dans les profils on a eu dans l'est
en tout cas 64 % de femmes ce qui est
quand même assez important et 76 % de
nos catégories socioprofessionnelles
plus voilà supérieur alors du coup quel
est le principal enseignement que saint
quentin en yvelines tire de cette
enquête
alors d'abord ça veut dire que c'est une
enquête qui confirme l'attractivité de
51 corps pour vivre et aussi pour pour
travailler ça tombe bien puisque dans ma
délégation j'ai eu si l'attractivité des
territoires donc c'est plutôt
encourageant
ça confirme également justement le set
de télétravail dans une une
agglomération où le cadre de vie est
agréable puisque côté espaces verts on
ressort de façon assez forte
c'est une ville c'est une communauté
d'agglomération également kipré mais
permet des pratiques sportives le plus
simple alors quand on télétravail n'est
pas en train de faire du sport bien
entendu mais ça peut permettre d'avoir
des moments de pause et de détente un
peu plus nature voire sportive voilà et
puis c'est aussi une enquête qui
conforte qui confirme en tout cas
l'importance des commerces de proximité
puisque les gens les des commerces de
proximité je me permets de vous
interrompre dans le détail de ce sondage
vous vous êtes interrogé donc comme vous
le disiez sur l'impact du télétravail
sur ces commerces de proximité il serait
davantage fréquenté alors le chiffre
c'est 43% des sondés qui les fréquentent
ray davantage quel est l'enjeu alors du
télétravail
au vu de ces résultats pour le
développement économique d'une
agglomération tels que saint quentin en
yvelines
alors ça veut dire qu'ils veulent qu'il
faut s'adapter parce que tout est en vie
de dire que tous les petits commerces
non tous les commerces de proximité noms
ressortent pas forcément gagnant par
exemple si vous parlez avec les
pressings
ils ont forcément moins de clients
puisque les gens vont peut-être moins un
portait de de costumes de tailleurs
qu'ils iront faire ensuite nettoyé et
puis je pense que pour les restaurants
également alors ne parle même pas des
videmment de l'intérieur de dramatique
qui sont en train de vivre
mais pour les restaurants il ya
également besoin de base
les gens vont moins au restaurant voilà
mais du coup il faut ressortir une
demande de plus grande diversité alors
dans la restauration
et puis également dans les produits ou
auxquels ils ont accès je crois qu'on a
aussi assisté à un boom de l'an viii
d'avoir des produits issus de circuits
courts voilà donc ça c'est des choses
qui ressorte beaucoup plus clairement
grâce à ce grâce à cette enquête alors
est-ce que cet état des lieux fait suite
j'imagine à l'augmentation du
télétravail avec la pandémie et cette
fameuse crise sanitaire dont vous l'avez
évoqué juste à l'instant
et oui tout à fait c'est c'était
important parce que beaucoup de gens qui
ont répondu par contre sont des habitués
le télétravail c'est à dire que c'est
pas là ce n'était pas loin des puits de
nouveautés pour tout le monde puisque on
peut dire que il ya 40% parmi les gens
qui reproduit 40 % seulement ont
commencé pendant l'année du confinement
donc c'est des pratiques qui étaient
déjà habituel et l enquête fait
également ressortir le souhait pour les
angles de télétravail et deux à trois
jours par semaine
même lorsqu'on sera sortie de cette
crise donc ça montre que le télétravail
peut apporter une certaine qualité de
vie mais qui en même temps les gens
veulent continuer à garder contact et
bien sûr avec leur avec leurs collègues
ça reste quand même un peu moins
important et donc ça fait ressortir
oui si je les écoute ça fait juste pour
finir ça comme je le disais on va
écouter l'entreprise les oraux située à
montigny le bretonneux le travail
justement chez elle était déjà en place
pour ces 19 collaborateurs valerie olek
la dirigeante de cette entreprise
spécialisée dans la commercialisation de
téléphones et mobiles destinés aux
seniors au micro de nicolas landry
[Musique]
saint quentin en yvelines en fêtes
d'auros et la filiale française du
groupe de rock est un groupe
international suédois qui commercialise
en fait des produits de téléphonie
simplifiée pour les seniors sur saint
quentin dans con et que 19 dont
l'activité est essentiellement on va
dire tourner autour de la
commercialisation des produits
[Musique]
on avait déjà un accord de télétravail
avant d'être dans cette situation de
crise sanitaire du fait d'être en couple
international on avait tous les outils
informatiques de connexion à distance
donc on a pu réagir très vite et mettre
en place le télétravail quasiment au
jour 1 du premier confinement nos
missions commerciales le permettent à
nos clients sont aussi très
majoritairement en télétravail
ça s'est très très bien passé au début
on sait bien organisés en plus on avait
en vous connectant télétravail complet
donc des petites réunions qu'on appelle
gardons le lien et qui permettait
effectivement d'être vraiment en lien
malgré tout le fait qu'on ait mis en
place sur ce deuxième confinement une
présence permanente
je vous ai expliqué les raisons
pratiques mais il y avait aussi des
raisons un petit peu plus parfois
psychologique et matériel pour des
salariés dont les conditions on va dire
de logement personnel de vie personnelle
finalement rendez-le télétravail sur le
long terme assez pénible nous valérie
olek rejoint un petit peu ce que vous
disiez alexandra rosetti dans votre
sondage 71 % des personnes interrogées
veulent tout de même garder un lien
social avec leurs collègues également 68
personnes par dont 68 % aimeraient
pratiquer le télétravail seulement deux
à trois jours par semaine alors
télétravail et oui mais pas tous les
jours on comprend bien voilà pas
forcément tous les jets au ski ce qui
ressort aussi c'est justement je disais
faut faire évoluer les habitudes et
c'est aussi dans les espaces de travail
ce qui ressort aussi c'est que des
espaces de coworking son vont être
amenés à se développer parce que
travailler dans son
salon même si la plupart des gens quand
même des logements assez spacieux mais
c'est pas évident surtout si le couple
ou travail est en télétravail c'est pas
évident de cohabiter dans un même espace
dans un même appartement par exemple
donc les espaces de coworking vont
devoir également se développer il y en a
déjà mais il faut quand justement qu'on
améliore la communication sur ces lieux
et je pense que toutes les communes de
saint quentin
bien sûr s'intéresser à ce sujet vous
avez des projets des espaces de
coworking à développer à implanter
supplémentaires à l'agglo oui on est on
est en train d'y travailler justement on
travaille sur plusieurs choses sur ce
type de projet on travaille également
sur ce qu'on appelle les tiers lieu
c'est-à-dire des endroits qui peuvent
accueillir des entreprises pour des
formations pour des rencontres des
débats
enfin pour différentes thématiques donc
l'agglomération de saint quentin est
vraiment en train de déployer toutes ses
forces pour pouvoir améliorer l'accueil
des gens qui sont en télétravail ou
permettre aux entreprises de
déconcentrer un petit peu de modes de
travail
dernière question alexandra rose est ici
le travail le télétravail pardon venait
à se généraliser à 100%
quelles seraient les conséquences sur
les infrastructures les transports en
commun et bien d'autres choses pour une
agglomération comme saint quentin en
yvelines qui possède énormément
justement d'entreprises sur le
territoire
alors ce serait sans doute pas une très
bonne chose puisque alors c'est sûr
d'appoigny circulation s'est toujours
beaucoup mieux on a vu pendant le
dernier confirmant l'impact d'avoir tout
le monde à la maison évidemment été très
bénéfique pour ça mais sinon je pense
qu'on y perdrait aussi en dynamique et
en vie en vie sociale tout simplement
alors il ya beaucoup de projets
d'immobilier d'entreprise sur saint
quentin qui continue à se développer
donc ça la marque de l'attractivité de
saint quentin
mais je pense qu'à l'intérieur de ces
projets bien il faut aussi apprendre à
adapter
les femmes les façon d'accueillir les
accueillir les salariés
donc ça c'est tout un travail qu'on a
toujours en cours aussi avec avec nos
entreprises avec les promoteurs qui font
de l'immobilier d'entreprise merci
alexandra rosetti d'avoir été avec neuf
le prix merci à vous toujours dans cette
thématique du télétravail les
confinements et le recours à cette
pratique des gens mais augmenter
favorise les aménagements des maisons et
des appartements
depuis quelques mois les architectes et
décorateurs d'intérieur voit venir de
nouveaux clients prêts à rendre leur
logement plus approprié au travail
reportage la stricte bergère et pierre
hugot reiber travailler chez soi
nécessite d'avoir un espace agréable et
aménager qu'il soit dans le salon dans
la chambre ou dans la cuisine
certains salariés veulent pouvoir être à
l'aise ils font donc appel à des
architectes et décorateurs d'intérieur
lagence fait beaucoup demandent depuis
la mise en place du confinement un
salarié qui travaille chez lui de façon
confortable agréable sur un espace qui
est fonctionnel constitue pour sa
société une meilleure valeur ajoutée
c'est clair donc
on a besoin d'être bien pour travailler
chez cette cliente
un projet de rénovation de la cuisine
avait déjà été entamée mais avec
l'arrivée du confinement et du
télétravail tout a été repensé il ya eu
des variations d'un point de vue
matériaux puisque le client a souhaité
mettre son poing de bureau de travail au
centre névralgique de la maisonnée donc
la cuisine les matériaux étaient
beaucoup plus foncez donc on a apporté
des notes beaucoup plus fraîche et jouer
avec vraiment la lumière pour que
l'espace soit beaucoup plus lumineux un
plan de travail clair des meubles blancs
à la place de bleu canard une grande
verrière ouverte sur le salon et une
décoration épurée
l'appliance voit vraiment la différence
avec le début du premier confinement je
suis retrouvé enfermé dans mes quatre
murs de chambre sur une petite table
ronde comme ça c'était un peu compliqué
et j'avoue que j'ai j'ai respiré quoi
quand on a refait notre espion l'espace
en bas c'était totalement différent
selon une enquête réalisée par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines sur 2000 personnes 92 % d'entre
elles disent apprécier de télé
travailler sur ce territoire
l'actualité c'est aussi la campagne de
vaccination contre le coc u19 qui se
poursuit en ile de france plus de 40
mille six cents personnes sont désormais
vacciner les personnes de 75 ans et plus
peuvent d'ailleurs d'ores et déjà
s'inscrire notamment sur d'octo libre
pour leur futur vaccination qui
démarrera à partir de lundi 18 janvier
je rappelle qu uniquement le personnel
soignant de plus de 50 ans pouvait se
faire vacciner jusqu'à lors le ministre
de la santé olivier vers en a d'ailleurs
annoncé hier qu'un décompte global et
par région serait mise en ligne tous les
soirs à 19h30 sur le site du ministère
de la santé et la question de la
vaccination son déploiement sera à
développer analyser et débattus dans le
7-8 société présentée par mélanie poquet
à partir de 18h30
et si on parle beaucoup de vaccination
en ce moment les dépistages eux aussi
continue contre le coc vie de 19 ce
samedi 16 janvier un dépistage est
organisé aux clayes-sous-bois gratuit et
sans rendez vous ces tests sont gérées
par la croix rouge
donc ce sera des tests anti dziennik
avec un résultat sous 20 minutes ce sera
de 10 heures
à 13 heures et de 14 heures à 17 heures
à l'espace philippe noiret également la
ville d'andrésy en partenariat avec la
région ile de france organise elle aussi
une opération gratuite de dépistage
antigénique ce samedi 16 janvier ce sera
au complexe stéphane diagana de 10h à
13h et de 14h à 17h réduire les
nuisances sonores tout en produisant de
l'énergie pour la vie urbaine c'est
l'ambition de l'entreprise d'exel
industries qui teste aux mureaux depuis
six mois un mur antibruit photovoltaïque
les explications de frédéric d'artois
directeur général de techspace
industries au micro de pierre hugot
reiber soundscan est à un mur antibruit
photovoltaïques dont qui s'adresse aux
abords de l'autoroute et de joie
ferroviaire est plutôt dans des zones
urbaines mais son but donc c'est 2 en
même temps améliorer lutter contre les
nuisances sonores et générer une
électricité photovoltaïque c'est un
c'est un mur acoustique donc
verticalement on a des panneaux
acoustiques qui vont atténuer le bruit
est au sommet de ces panneaux nous avons
qu on appelle une casquette
photovoltaïque c'est à dire que j'ai
panneaux photovoltaïques incliné comme
ça comme un forme de toise du mur là
haut niveau de l'expérimentation on a
bien tester la fonctionnalité acoustique
et production d'énergie mais l'enjeu
pour être aussi de rajouter des services
associés à ce mur antibruit donc mes
services liés à la route du suivi la
détection d'accidents de monitoring
environnementales ou des soutiens
risques liés à des recharge de véhicules
électriques pour pour les abords des
autoroutes
[Musique]
aujourd'hui alors qu'on est encore en
phase de développement sur des on va
dire des démonstrateurs on approche les
20 % de surcoûts donc avec l'ambition de
les diminuer grâce à des projets de
grande échelle donc là aujourd'hui on
travaillait au bureau c'est une longueur
de 5 mètres de mur et à tours on
travaille sur 100 m de murs mais ça
reste encore petit depuis le 18 décembre
2020 8 médiateurs sociaux sont déployés
sur la commune de la verrière du lundi
au dimanche ils vont à la rencontre des
habitants et des jeunes dans plusieurs
quartiers de la ville avec un double
objectif insertion sociale et
tranquillité publique
reportage de nicolas landry
alors que parce que trop lourd mais d
ibrahim font partie de l'équipe des
médiateurs sociaux de la verrière
ce soir là ils sont dans le quartier du
bois de l'étang pour parler avec les
jeunes présents dehors objectif faire de
la médiation
aucun moment on est là pour remplacer la
police ou quoi que ce soit là juste pour
donner un message
même si on est soudain quartier on peut
réussir dans la vie
c'est des fois dans la vie c'est pas
facile mais voilà on peut toujours s'en
sortir avec les bonnes personnes et on
paie toujours donc conseillé même si des
fois dans des familles s'attend à le
faire où chaque personne comme des
jeunes sont mal orientés donc nous on
est là tant pour les aider les orioles
orly-parc le bois de l'étang le village
les médiateurs sociaux se rendent dans
les différents quartiers de la commune
depuis le 18 décembre 2020 une équipe de
huit personnes soir six médiateurs
vacataires employé par la mairie et deux
agents de proximité co financé
principalement par l'état
parmi eux fabas macalou ce qu'on fait au
départ c'est qu'on vend contart on va on
fait connaissance avec les jeunes c'est
surtout ça qui est important au départ
on essaie de savoir ce qu'ils font dans
la vie parce qu'il préserve personnes
qui sont depuis 10 ans dans ce quartier
pour le plat ni à deux adultes au relais
de la préfecture qui travaillent du
lundi au vendredi et pour les vacataires
eux ils font du vendredi samedi dimanche
et sont amenés aussi à travailler les
jours fériés cité j'aime cette idée des
médiateurs sociaux une proposition de
nicolas dainville durant la campagne des
municipales de 2020 une dimension
sociale être à l'écouté des jeunes
instaurer un dialogue essayer de les
orienter au mieux dans leurs activités
leur recherche d'emploi
et puis une dimension tranquillité
publique pour rappeler les règles de
comportement de respect du voisinage
pour que tout se passe bien dans un
quartier la municipalité est
actuellement en discussions avec les
bailleurs sociaux présents sur la
commune
objectif construire des partenariats
avec eux autour de la médiation sociale
un mode sport enfin et plus précisément
de tennis est l'un des sportifs y vinoy
à suivre en cette année 2010 21 son nom
antoine ghibaudo à tout juste 15 ans
tennisman qui s'entraîne au comité des
yvelines de feucherolles fait partie des
meilleurs jeunes de sa génération
son portrait avec michael almy d'euros
il est l'une des plus belles promesses
du tennis français à 15 ans antoine
ghibaudo fait partie de la nouvelle
génération des tennismen appelé à
briller sur la scène internationale le
tennis une discipline que le sportif
d'un mètre 87 a connu très jeune j'ai
commencé le tennis à trois ans avec mon
père parce que lui aussi joué
du coup il m'a fait essayer j'ai tout de
suite aimé ça du coup c'est comme ça que
j'ai commencé je me souviens que j'ai
tout de suite aimé aimer ce sport très
rapidement antoine s'inscrit dans le
club de sa ville saint léger en yvelines
avant de partir au perray en yvelines
aujourd'hui ce spécialiste des surfaces
dures et fun de rafael nadal s'entraîne
quasi quotidiennement comité des
yvelines de feucherolles en étant
licencié au tennis club des loges à
saint germain des mois journée en
général c'est
je m'échauffe 30 minutes après je fais
deux heures de tennis je refais deux
heures de physique et deux heures de
tennis après et je finis souvent par la
récupération 30 45 minutes à
l'entraînement payant le sportif qui
sert à plus de 185 kilomètres heure a
été ces dernières années champion
d'europe par équipes et les champions de
france
il a également atteint les demi-finales
du petit as antoine bibeau doit
également participer en 2020 pour la
première fois roland garros juniors le
tennisman a été éliminée au troisième
tour
forcément c'est mon rêve de jouer ce
tournoi là et d'essayer de les gagner
aussi du coup on est forcément c'était
c'était une super expérience j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance de dos pour le faire
satisfait
oui
après j'aurais bien aimé
aller plus loin quand même parce que le
but c'est quand même pas de se contenter
d'un une victoire en premier temps mais
décide de gagner les temps il est tombé
comme ça en 2021 antoine gillot a de
grandes ambitions il espère participer
aux différents grands chelems et
notamment roland garros juniors et il
envisage également de disputer les
tournois sur le circuit professionnel
mondial les étapes importantes pour
atteindre son objectif
être numéro un mondial c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
retrouver grégory canal et dans le 7-8
journal demain à 18 heures et d'ici là
une très bonne soirée à vous
[Musique]